President Biden accused of siding with
oppressive regimes over American
interest
after giving Chevron a green light to
drill oil and socialist Venezuela in
easing sanctions critics questioning why
do business with the country that
according to a recent U.N report is
responsible for crimes against humanity
the move also comes months after Saudi
Arabia snubbed Biden's request for them
to produce more oil our very own peter
Ducey pressing the White House about it
why is it the President Biden would
rather let U.S companies drill for oil
in Venezuela the and here in the U.S
that's not an accurate take on the
president's view there are plenty of
opportunities for oil and gas companies
to drill here in the United States does
the president think there's some benefit
to the cloud
oil and
to do with a benefit to The Climate
feeder again there are 9 000 unused
permits here in the United States
judge what's your thinking on this I
know you've shared past we should drill
here do you think we should drill here
in Venezuela or just here
I don't think we should drill in
Venezuela I think that on the one hand
you know Maduro is a dictator and we
have criticized him and now all of a
sudden we're on our knees to him look
we've got enough rigs in Louisiana and
in Texas to be able to drill off of
those existing Rigs and they've got the
most sophisticated refineries in this
country uh for the Canadian crude oil
that I've said before if we put together
Canada the United States and Mexico we
would be energy Independents he should
be interested in increasing the economy
of the United States as opposed to the
economy of Venezuela Venezuela what what
what motivates the president of the
United States to cut back on sanctions
for a country that we supposedly don't
respect and disagree with totally to say
hey can you sell us some oil when we
could do it here and this argument that
you know what we've got 9 000 leases
they don't have the roads to the leases
the regulations will take forever effort
to be filled it's really a shame we need
U.S production we've got it here and
he's not willing to do it and I'm not
going to say anymore Dana can you think
of is there any
geopolitical strategic reason why we
would want the Venezuelans producing oil
versus us well I mean that's not for me
to that's for the White House to
described to us and we're not we
shouldn't have to sit here and guess
what they're trying to do they should
try to explain it to us that's their
obligation and I don't think that they
did that today and I think that the
spokesperson would probably agree
because he probably is thinking what are
we doing like could you point to point
to me somewhere where Venezuela has
taken a step that makes us think that oh
they're on the road back to democracy
and that they should be able to allow
this and um
the other thing I would point out is the
bite Administration they're basically
doing the speed dating to try to figure
out anybody in America will drill will
drill for oil for us except for
ourselves that you should actually date
here at home you can find some nice
people the final thing I would say is on
uh political Europe had this story today
the Europeans are furious with the Biden
administration because all of these
green subsidies are screwing at the
Green Tech markets and so now we have a
situation where you know like we get mad
because China subsidizes their
Industries and it puts us in an
uncompetitive position well if we've
just done that to Europe and apparent
according to the article when the
European leaders brought this up to
Biden at the G20 a couple of weeks ago
he seemed unaware of the issue
that's not good
uh Greg are you surprised that the
president was unaware of an issue yeah
uh shocked I was shocked to dismayed uh
by the way I here's why we're Drilling
in Venezuela because our we have very
dirty ugly oil our oil is racist it's
homophobic uh our oil has been around
through really bad times and never spoke
out against it
100 years our oil has remained silent I
don't want that oil in my car I want oil
from Venezuela that's what I want I want
a morally Superior oil but it really is
funny this is like saying uh like that's
kind of what it is it's a virtue signal
saying hey we we're we're
environmentally sound but it's like
saying you know what I don't have any
junk food in my house but I go out and
eat at McDonald's Burger King Wendy's
Chick-fil-A or upstairs or upstairs for
that matter and but I go no junk food in
the house for me and I'm 500 pounds so
this is this it just it just shows you
that this it's it's about how we look
not what we're actually doing that
matters obviously we think less of
Venezuela to be happy endangering their
environment right
yeah well I have Chevron in my portfolio
so I'm very happy that we're exploring
Western Hemisphere I see this story in
the
my mind Harold what's Bernie Sanders
thinking because Bernie Sanders is a
socialist and socialism destroyed
Venezuela decimated their oil
infrastructure is that a good thing to
Bernie I don't know
where he honeymooned Russia controls
through their little puppet Maduro and
so Joe Biden goes in there to a country
that's swimming in loose AK-47s they're
in every jungle in every slum thanks to
Castro and he says we're not going to
build windmills off the coast we're
going to cut a deal so chevron's
investors can get back paid their debts
that they're owed by Caracas so where's
Bernie on this has he put out a press
statement what does Bernie get such a
pass on all this stuff wrong and I'm on
to him yeah you are you're on to him I
can smell it Jesse Watters Prime Time
special you know we're gonna do a big
investigation you should do it for the
weekend now a two-hour special two hours
special whose two hours should I take uh
does anybody want but just as you come
in and do it live do it live yes that's
a note for me though
up next woke education is such a problem
people are paying big bucks to get
deprogrammed I want to Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now